la santé au travail fortement impacté
par la crise sanitaire pour garantir le
bien-être et accompagner les salariés
plusieurs entreprises chinoises ont mis
en place des protocoles le ministre en
charge de la santé au travail était en
visite à méré pour découvrir et
valoriser ces mesures on voulait ici
marqué la capacité des tpe pme dans
notre pays à la fois à porter
l'attention nécessaire à la santé de
leurs salariés mais aussi à proposer une
qualité de vie au travail
à ses côtés aurore bergé selon la
députée yvelinoise crise sanitaire ou
pas le bien-être est un enjeu de tous
les jours et aussi un accompagnement de
ceux justement qui sont en lien
permanent avec les entreprises avec les
demandeurs d'emploi avec les salariés
donc c'est vraiment tout cet ensemble
qu'on est en place ici à méré le
bien-être au travail se traduit de
différentes manières selon les
entreprises
ambiance familiale assistance pour les
déplacements de charges lourdes ou
encore ostéopathie céder la logistique
automatisé cd monte charge électrique
c'est tout ce qu'on peut faire au mieux
pour les salariés mais c'est aussi trois
séances ostéo par ans et de séminaires
on some salle écoute vraiment d'aider
des attentes des uns et des autres pour
ceux qui ont des problèmes de d'enfants
de
d'organisation d'horaires dans la
famille on peut organiser leur journée
en fonction vraiment de deux de leurs
besoins une proposition de loi pour
renforcer la prévention en santé au
travail serait examiné à partir de ce
lundi 15 février par l'assemblée
nationale